swirls of interest as Italy's Prime
Minister Matteo Renzi arrives in
Strasbourg to see in his country's
presidency of the EU the first in the
new parliamentary cycle after Mays
elections before his main address he had
this for Italian Amy peas credo che
questo IL tempo nel qualika Roger Luo
Senora hasty mr. Renzi knows of what he
speaks as a novice in politics he was
spooned into his post this year from the
mayorship of Florence within no time his
stock rose so much that his democratic
party was the leader in the European
elections fresh eyes on old problems
sahaja Europa fascism selfie came
machine available for a merger a bay l
volto de las tangas and a solution la
vera grandes fille de que a dfrnt SI IL
nostro continente Oh Jerry trovare Lana
medela ropa migration energy climate and
growth are the buzzwords of this
presidency and in these hard European
rules will play their part mr. Renzi
wants more attention paid to the growth
part of the EU stability and growth pact
the mechanism for managing budget
deficits while restraining dead cello
stabilizer ma chan ka-lok roshita en la
rejest ad avere lock received a comb
elemento fundamentally de la política
economical repair not so fast say the
germans who say there's already plenty
of flexibility in the stability pact for
italy and not long ago a country staring
into the economic abyss to achieve its
aims it's missing be flexible evidence
miss nevada snowy owls Liggins miss
matiz normal voice elizabeth ington
exogenous mr. file she week we musn't
alexion diva Gillian Tom further any
peace the speech was short on detail and
even shorter on ideas so late actually
transaction finally home it Pappy solido
capital T fundo plus de faux pas vie de
la prochaine tax retraction velocity of
the to go to nfg clima can you know de
l'énergie the final word to mr. Renzi
who said communication courage and
growth are the keys to exiting the
crisis and that Italy sees a big
opportunity for all three during its
presidency now
time for that selfie